la democracia ganó en Brasil eso afirmó
el presidente del tribunal superior
electoral Alessandra de moraes quien
instó a los seguidores bolsonaristas a
Cesar los movimientos de protesta por
los resultados en los comicios del
domingo y advirtió con iniciar procesos
penales a los autores
las elecciones terminaron el ganador se
investirá el 19 de diciembre y asumir el
cargo el 1 de enero de 2023 estos
democracia esto es alternancia de poder
Este es el estado republicano No hay
forma de impugnar un resultado
publicitado democráticamente los
responsables de estos movimientos
antidemocráticos serán investigados y
responsabilizados con base en la ley las
manifestaciones que incluyeron bloqueos
de camiones y hasta un período de
intervención militar en la puerta de
cuarteles en decenas de ciudades
disminuyeron luego de que el propio Jair
bolsonaro las desalentara el miércoles
por la noche
en tanto que los equipos de bolsonaro y
Lula iniciaron la transición de gobierno
nuestra tarea fue nuestro trabajo es
unir a Brasil trabajar y tener una
agenda de propuestas para mejorar la
vida de las personas sigamos adelante la
transición comenzó y la haremos de la
mejor manera posible
las reuniones contaron con la presencia
de almin el coordinador de campaña de
Lula y disputados izquierdistas junto al
responsable de la propuesta del
presupuesto para 2023 y el jefe de
gabinete de bolsonaro las reuniones dan
inicio al proceso que finalizará con la
toma de Posesión del nuevo presidente el
primero de enero